alors est ce que gilles verdez vous
résumer la faire parce que c'est plus en
fait oui c'est une affaire qui s'est
effectivement étiré et qui a donné lieu
récemment à un procès pour fraude
fiscale
globalement où vous reprocher d'avoir
dissimulé de l'argent en suisse
notamment et d'avoir échappé au fisc le
quai à une condamnation pour l'aspect
fraude fiscale en septembre 2019 quatre
ans de prison ferme 10 ans d'inégibilité
et puis il ya eu aussi une relaxe sur
des affaires de blanchiment et de
corruption
voilà et là maintenant on parle de
pourvoi en cassation
donc moi ma question madame elle est
simple il ya un faisceau d'affaires
comment vous vivez ça est ce qu'un jour
vous pensez qu'on verra le bout de ses
affaires parce que je signale simplement
que votre mari a été placé en janvier en
garde à vue pour une nouvelle affaire
qui concernerait un endroit qui auraient
été loués vos proches ont été entendus
ça ne s'arrête pas à madame les affaires
avec vous alors écoutez cher monsieur je
voudrais d'abord je remercie de la
manière dont vous avez présenté les
choses parce qu'il ya évidemment des
choses qui me tiennent à coeur et que je
souhaite dire premièrement je souhaite
dire que effectivement la condamnation
que nous n'avons eu nous la méritons
tout simplement parce que effectivement
nous avons caché au fisc du patrimoine
familial
alors pour mon mari un père déporté un
père qui venu en france nous sommes des
enfants d'immigrés tous les deux patrick
son père est venu en france il a fait de
la résistance il a été dénoncé s'est
retrouvé à auschwitz il en est sorti
parce qu'il a été dénoncé comme
résistant et pas comme juif très bien et
bien après quand il a gagné beaucoup
d'argent
il a souhaité vous savez comme disaient
nos grands mères maintenant que je suis
grand mère je peux le dire vous allez
les tout vous dire que je suis une bonne
humeur
bon eh bien il a souhaité ne pas mettre
tous ses oeufs dans le même panier
voilà quant à moi pareil on vient de
tunisie
nous sommes juifs et mon père aussi a
souhaité d'une part mon père a souhaité
m mais ce n'est pas tellement mon père
c'est surtout à l'âme
hors de mon père au décès de mon père
mon frère et ma soeur aînée
malheureusement mon très fortement les
et comme a pu s'en rendre compte
le juge van ruymbeke qui est aller les
interroger et pour ne pas que ça se voit
si je puis dire
ils sont émigrés vers la suisse et puis
à un moment donné où j'étais en
faiblesse dans ma vie parce que vous
savez je viens d'amour en 1 conques 3
incroyable avec mon mari excusez moi ça
m'en fais mes billets quand je parle de
lui depuis 44 ans nous allons avoir 45
ans de mariage dans deux mois mais la
vie d'un couple il ya des hauts des bas
je suppose que vous l'avez tous vécu
castaldi dépit des vives ont essayé puis
tous d'accord on va dire qu'à un moment
donné on va dire mettez la en veilleuse
les garçons
[Rires]